we are told a pig runs rightward 20
meters to eat a juicy apple
it then walks leftward 5 meters to eat a
nut
finally it walks leftward another 25
meters to eat another nut
the total time taken by the pig was 300
seconds
what was the pig's average velocity and
average speed over this time and assume
rightwards is positive and leftwards is
negative and round your answer to two
significant digits so pause this video
and try to work it out on your own
all right now let's do this together and
first let's just draw a diagram of what
is going on so this is our pig it first
runs rightward 20 meters so we can say
that's a positive 20 meter displacement
so it goes plus
20 meters
ends up right over there then it walks
leftwards five meters so then from there
it's going to walk leftwards five meters
so we could call that a negative five
meter displacement
and then finally it walks leftward
another 25 meters
so then it walks leftward another 25
meters so it gets right over there so
that'd be a displacement of negative 25
meters to eat another nut so it ends up
right over it ends up right over there
now to figure out our average velocity
let me write it down so our velocity
average and even this is one dimensional
it is a vector it has direction to it we
we specify the direction with the sign
positive being right words being
positive and left words being negative
you often times for one-dimensional
vectors might not see an arrow there or
might not see it bolded and just written
like this but our average velocity is
going to be equal to you could view it
as our displacement or a change in x
divided by how much time has actually
elapsed
and so what is our displacement going to
be let's see we have plus 20 meters and
then we have
minus 5 meters
and then we go to the left another 25
meters minus 25 meters and then all of
that is going to be over the elapsed
time or change in time all of that is
over 300 seconds so what is this
numerator going to be this is 20
minus 30 so that's going to be equal to
negative 10.
so this is equal to negative 10 meters
over
300 seconds over 300 seconds so the
average velocity is going to be equal to
negative 1
30th
meters per second the negative specifies
that on average the velocity is towards
the left if you want to specify this as
a decimal with two significant digits
this is going to be so it's
approximately equal to 0.033
that would be 1 30.
now let's try to tackle average speed
so
our speed r sometimes is used for speed
r for rate our average speed
is not going to be our displacement
divided by our elapsed time it is going
to be our distance
divided by our elapsed time and we'll
see that these are not going to be the
same thing that's the whole one of the
points of this problem
so our distance divided by elapsed time
so what's our distance traveled what's
going to be the absolute value of each
of these numbers so it's going to be 20
meters plus 5 meters
plus 25 meters
notice there's a difference here we're
not subtracting the 5 and the 25 we're
just adding all of that we just care
about the magnitudes divided by 300
seconds and so this is going to be equal
to 50 meters
50 meters over 300 seconds which is
equal to
5 over 30 which is equal to 1 6 of a
meter per second and if we want to write
it as a decimal let's see 6 goes into 1.
let's put some zeros here
6 goes into 10
one time 1 times 6 is 6. i could scroll
down a little bit
and then we subtract we get a four six
goes into
40 six times six times six is 36 and
we're still and then we get let me
scroll down again a little bit more
again
and then we get another
we get another four and then we're just
going to keep getting sixes over here so
this is going to be approximately equal
to
0.1 if we want two significant digits 1
meters per second
and
we are done we figured out the average
velocity and the average speed